what's going on everyone battlefield one
is here ready to rock your world war one
cravings from the soaring skies to the
mud deep trenches multiplayer and
battlefield one is composed of some
amazing moments of conquest with
teammates and to give you soldiers the
leg up here's our first Tips & Tricks
kicking things off let's focus on the
assault class I will primary weapons and
gadgets you should go for first the
starting MP 18 trench machine gun packs
decent power but has a nightmarish
recoil I recommend buying the m97 trench
backboard shotgun this shotgun packs the
numbers with high damage and great
hipfire accuracy the range of this
weapon is surprising with easy one to
two shots at close range and three to
four shots medium range to kill your
target I never had trouble racking up
the kill count with this shotgun
even up against machine gun packing
opponents also your starting m1911
pistol has the power to hit range
targets that your shot II can't
speaking of range the gadget you should
focus on grabbing is the 80 rocket gun
this weapon has the power to hit targets
the small length of a football field and
does heavy damage to vehicle and
infantry alike combining your shotgun
with your long range rocket gun right
out of the gate will be a nightmare in
the field for your enemies
up next is the metaclass with finally a
semi-automatic rifle that packs the
punch with tolerable recoil it's a
Savalas teller the Sebastin subasta look
close enough em 1916 factory rifle
packin great damage and good accuracy
this rifle can hold its own even in
outnumbered situations with three to
four shots to the body and a well-placed
headshot will bring your enemy down with
plenty of rounds left for his or her
friends I recommend crouching when you
can with this weapon to reduce recoil
when playing as a medic your main and
fastest way to level up is reviving your
teammates surprisingly not so much in
dropping health packs instead use that
health packs lot to get the rifle
grenade packing more stopping power
since the beta I will play shot on the
back of any vehicle can bring it to a
blazing halt giving you and your
teammates the time to finish it off
following right behind is the support
class with believe it or not one of the
starting weapons does a good job and
both giving you kills and suppressing
your enemies the M 1909 Bennett mercy
storm light machine gun may lack the
damage but its control makes it a great
sticking to weapon making this weapon
easy to use will allow you to invest
your war bonds and buying mortars do
your best to get close to the flags and
the enemy and consider bringing ammo
packs to consistently hammer your enemy
with infinite mortar power
last but not least is a Scout class with
some of the highest damaging weapons in
the game the go-to rifle for me starting
out once you have the credit is the
groover m95 infantry personally I don't
like using scoped rifle since they can
give away your position
thanks to that glare off the scope and
you have to hold your breath or lay on
your stomach for a steady shot the m95
is a scope free rifle meaning no glare
no holding your breath and laying on
your stomach for a steady aimed shot
instead this rifle is packin a high
damage accuracy rate that will test your
iron sight skills but believe me when I
tell you that once you master this rifle
you will notice a significant increase
in your iron sight skill accuracy across
the board thanks to the difficulty using
this gun also gadget wise to stand out
the first is the flare gun flash shot
that as it names States can blind your
enemies and light them on fire if hit by
the shot the second is the sniper decoy
which is a stick with a crashed head
dummy on top with a helmet that if shot
at by enemies their positions will
become known to you on the map
for grenades that you can equip for all
classes try using the incendiary grenade
useful in both fleshing out enemies and
quick retreat cover this grenade can
help take lives and save your own melee
weapon serve as more of a statement than
a stat wise hear anything from knives to
axes can kill your foes with just a few
hits or an instant kill depending upon
where you hit them there you have it
folks a quick look at what weapons for
each class you should try out to help
bring your kill count up and your death
count down if you have any load outs you
want to share feel free to in the
comments below and we'll see you guys on
the battlefield for more coverage on
battlefield one keep it here on gamespot
you